on the first Monday of May
New York's East Side becomes the center
of high fashion and for this year's met
galagues were instructed to dress in
honor of Carl Carl lagerfel that is some
guests paid homage to his signature
Style with looks from the fashion houses
where he spent decades working while
others walked that not so red carpet
dressed in bedazzled costumes or
t-shirts and bucket hats
folks editor-in-chief and lagerfell's
close friend Anna Wintour came in a
simple tribute a vintage Chanel she's
been running the Met Gala since 1995.
this is a lot of media attention around
the evening and we're very very grateful
to that because it also puts the
spotlight on the exhibition which is
also the primary another primary reason
that we do the evening is we want to
bring visitors into the museum